the traffic light government would like to
Deport rejected asylum seekers more quickly.
about the planned law
is now to be voted on Thursday.
according to this,
detention on is to be reduced from 10 to 28 so far
Days to be extended.
this is reported by the Bild newspaper.
except
of which are minors and families with children.
Exception juvenile repeat offenders.
they can still be placed in detention pending.
also against smugglers
is to be tougher in the future.
North Rhine-Westphalia.
Minister President Hendrik had deserted
in view of the survey high of the
AfD to an alliance of the center
called upon in migration policy.
the elimination of subsidies for farmers was
apparently planned almost 1 year in advance.
this is reported by the Bild newspaper.
according to this,
the decision,
to abolish the motor vehicle tax exemption for tractors,
already fallen in January of last year.
and consensual without
Protest by the traffic light parties or the opposition.
last had
Union and AfD at the
Protests sided with peasants.
during her winter exam,
the CSU had
even the president of the farmers' association,
Joachim Ruckweet,
invited as a guest.